hey guys we are back to work back to
school back to being cool and just on
the fly
I like rhymes hey guys i'm abby Shar
welcome to Abby's kitchen so a lot of
you are probably heading back to school
or work and you're probably thinking oh
I gotta pack another lunch I get it
packing lunches suck especially when
you're not that excited about what's in
them if you're like most people you're
probably always just switching in
between you know salad and sandwich
salad sandwich salad sandwich sandwich
all sandwich is always a salad sandwich
let's get a little exhausting right
you're not very excited about that so I
thought we would do the lovechild of the
salad and the sandwich and make cold
rolls three ways cold rolls are awesome
they're like little bundles of
deliciousness packed with all the
contents of your fridge all your
favorite leftovers so I'm gonna clear
out my fridge chop up lots of vegetables
and make an amazing lunch that you are
not gonna want to trade for dunkaroos
everybody in your lunch room is gonna be
jelly so let's do this first my Greek
salad wrap I transfer my rice paper
wraps to a bowl of warm water until
softened and transfer them to a clean
workstation I add some shredded romaine
cooked couscous grilled chicken tomatoes
cucumber red onion
feta and olives and now it's time to
roll I start by folding in the sides and
then I roll the whole thing up
really nice and tight next let's make a
quick little dip I start with some extra
virgin olive oil red wine vinegar
mustard honey oregano and a pinch of
salt pepper to taste
next up my shrimp peanut roll to my rice
paper I add some cooked shrimp soba
noodles carrots avocado some red cabbage
and a mommy and cilantro and again I
tuck in those sides and roll everything
up
nice and tight
[Music]
to make a dip I add some natural peanut
butter coconut milk and some tamari
coconut sugar lime juice sriracha and a
pinch of salt and pepper to taste stir
it until it's smooth and enjoy
finally my orange beef and kemar rolls
to my rice paper wrap I add some cooked
quinoa oranges shredded beets goats
cheese almonds and mint wrap those sides
in and then roll it all up nice and
tight
and let's make a quick little dip I've
got some extra-virgin olive oil balsamic
vinegar mustard honey poppy seeds and
some salt pepper to taste mix it all up
and get dipping guys are you not so
excited to pack your lunch for tomorrow
honestly we've got three amazing cold
rolls they may look a little phallic but
trust me and they're gonna taste good
and everyone at the office is gonna be
super jealous all right so I don't even
know eeny meeny miny moe catch a cold
roll by the toe I'm going in for the
beat and the orange just look at that
color mm-hmm check out that color action
going in for a little dip into the poppy
seed balsamic dressing huh mm-hmm
these guys are so good you're not even
gonna want to go to work or school
you're just gonna want to stay home and
have a cold roll party so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video I want to know
what your favorite cold roll
combinations are what do you have in
your fridge that would make an amazing
lunch subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]